♪ >> Greg:HEY WANT TO SEE YOURB.
IS YOUR CABEHAORIGHL
RAD AR LIKEESSE WATTERS
AND HATED?
[LAUGHS]
AUGHS]
AND WHE BFING IN THE BACK OF
HUBER CARSROP YOUR RATING?
IT'S A QUEION GOINYWHE
TH K.
THEYE ADDED AN AITIONAL
ATURE TO YOUR RIDHARING APP
TOEE THE BREAKDOWN OTHETAR
RATIS THAT THEY'VE RECEIVE
FR THERIVERS.
EY HOPE THE N INFORMATION
WI HELYOU STOP BEI A
[BEP].
EAKI OF, TURNS ONEW YORKITY SHET
AVERE WRITER RATG IN T
COUNY.
WAS BECAUSE IT' FROM PAROLES
IT TO IMPROVEOURCORE THEY
RECOMMENDEING ON TIM NOT
MAKI A MESS I D'T E BOILED
CATFH LS YOU PLAN TO SHARE.
NICE I BET YOU HAVE A FLAESS
SCORE D'T Y?
U HA A SCORE?
Jane: ION'T GO
ANYWHERE.
SPOON YOU D'T GO ANYWHE?
>>anice: I GUESST'S OY.
Gre THERE IT IS
AT'S A GOOD SRE.
WHGAVE ME ANE?
>>reg: CUOMO, HOUSI.
HE HAS TO WK SOMEHOW.
MAYBE YOU ARIVEN BY CHRICUOMO M
FE LIKE A MENU T
ME BAD
SEE WHO GAVE THE T STA AND
>> I'VRIED
>> Greg: WENTO TE A LOT?
I DOT SEE HOW YOUID ON THIS.
THISSUNHIS ISIKE PLAYING
>> T.W.: THIS INEDY
EKEND.
Greg: THAT'S ILL NOT BAD.
THAT NHING.
SAVING THE WOR FOR LT.'M
CULAR THISRAPH.
I 4.82.
>> Greg: LOO AT HOW MANY
RIDES I'VE HAD.
>> TAKES THE SUBY.
ITS ALMOS SUBY JOY BEHAR.
Greg: I'M NEV IN  CAR
TRK, SE GOING SOMHERE
BUTHEN I COMING HOM I'M
NER DRUNK BECAUSI NEVER GO
HOME TSEE MY POINT?IT DEPEN IF R
WE WILL HE AONG DISCUION.
TYRU?
>> Tyr: HI FOUL ONHIS
ONE.
EY HAVE TO DOXTRATUFF FOR
ME -- I KNOW THE ALL FM
PUSH THE SEAT FWARDN THE
SERAL TIMES THEARS BEEN TOO
SMALL TS IS AN EXCEL.
YOU KNOW I SAYING?
I KW EXACTLY WHA YOUE
SAYING
>>yrus A THE CINEMA WAY
CAUSE THE CS TOO SMALL.
>> Greg: TT I AROBLEM
AT I WILL NER HE.
Tyrus: WHEN Y ASKIM TO
MOVE THE SEAUP A THEY GET
MATHEY'VE L TH WAY AROUND A
HEOES RLLY SLOW AND THEN IYOU AT
KNOW IT'SONNA BE B.>> Greg: 12
>> Tyrus: KNOWHENEVER IT'S
ALSOANTO ADJUST THE SEA
TH HAVE TO GETP ANGO
AROU.
OUT OF THEIR SEAT BECSE THE
BIGHEEK STOMACH, TY SM
STOMAC--
LET S WHAT YOU GOT.
>> DAN
>> Gg: 211 STARS.
Kat: I NOT FOR ERYON
AND TNS OUT THAT AOT O
HAPPEN TO DRIVHERUBERI HE 4.9 ST
MYOINGRONG?
>> Gg: WHAT?>> Kat: 21EOPL ARE E
ABSOLUTELY NOT
THEY SEE ME, NOTBSOLUTELY NOT.
I PROBLY WLD HAV 50.
>>reg: ALLF THAT WEEK, THE
CUSTOMER BEING JUDGE BY THE
OF A SERVI.N THOUGIT IS KIND
STARS ARE NOT TTIN WHAT I PUT
IN OUTF THIS.
>> Greg: TNG ABOUT THIS BUT
IF MONETIZEOOD HAVIOR.
RIGHT NOW SO TT YOU BE DOIN
OKAY, ANYING OVE A 4.8 GETS
10% OFF THR RID.
WHAT IFHAT SPREAD STHATF
U AT SRBUCKS -
TH IS WOU CE [EEP]
>> K: BUT I'M NOT [BLP].
>> 45EOPL DISAGE.
Kat Y, APPARENTLY
DEMOGRAPHIC I ESS.N THE
I'M T FOR EVERYONE.
>>